well Supreme Court Justice Elena Kagan
made a comment I see this flash on the
screen I was on Twitter at the time from
the hill Kagan warns that Supreme Court
legitimacy at risk if it Strays too far
from public sentiment
public sentiment I said let's see what
she said this I actually thought it was
a headline you know sometimes they put
these headlines out and they're not
actually what the person said I've had
it happen to me so I go to the page and
I read the quote so let's read it
together
I'm not talking about any particular
decision or even any particular series
of decisions but if over time the court
loses all connection with the public and
with public sentiment that's a dangerous
thing for a democracy no the headline
was accurate so I you know one of those
moments you know how it goes for me head
spins around
does she not understand her job
all I learned from this is that she
doesn't understand her job she's not
supposed to care she's a Supreme Court
Justice she's supposed to be issuing her
rulings based on the law she's not
supposed to care about public sentiment
all this told me is that Elena Kagan
decides how she's going to rule about
something based on the way the wind is
blowing that day oh right now these are
the issues that matter to people well
then I should rule like this oh in 10
years now the tide has turned and people
feel differently well now I should rule
like this so it's not about the law
again these people don't live in the
land of facts they don't they live in
this subjective kind of blurry it kind
of always looks like an impressionist
painting you know those paintings you go
into the museum from far away it's like
oh there's such Clarity you go up close
and it just looks like a bunch of dots
you're like what's going on you feel
like you're in some type of psychedelic
something
they live in the Land of Make-Believe
like this is utterly ridiculous also she
just told you how liberal Supreme Court
Justices think when these people talk
listen listen to what they're saying
they are telling you what they're doing
believe them the first time learn from
it and remember it this is that concept
of a living and breathing Constitution
where nothing really means anything this
is that concept of well the law means
you know X Y and Z it's the whole thing
it goes into the gender debate oh male
female what's that it's you know just
sort of this floating identity it's a
feeling it pervades everything is what
I'm saying to you so just be on the
lookout and this is why it becomes
really important to elect a president
that can nominate these people a lot of
people voted for Trump again not because
they were so excited about Trump or you
know maybe some of them were excited
about Trump but a lot of them were like
I have my reservation but we need those
Supreme Court Justices that don't think
like this that aren't going to make
their decisions based on the way the
wind is blowing that day that year that
minute what a dangerous thing to say and
also she said it public she just they
have no shame
they're proud of that stance they're not
worried that you or I are going to come
back and say well Elena that's not your
job sorry but you're not a political
commentator you're not supposed to be
looking at the mood of the con that's
not you're not a pollster you're you're
a Supreme Court Justice you know if you
can't do the job properly you shouldn't
be there you should not have that
enormous honor and responsibility
disgraceful absolutely so much so that I
had to pause my discussion of Pat
Benatar and who's who's public sentiment
the same people that never leave
Washington the same people that hang out
in New York and California and who's
public sentiment I doubt she watches Fox
News so what CNN MSNBC it's it's the
public sentiment of people who agree
with her politically right that's all
right it's the news outlets that agree
with her politically it's like the the
liberal enclaves throughout the country
I that's why you know we had that
conversation a few weeks ago about the
Electoral College and I know that can
get weedsy but you know that exists
because you don't want New York and
California and these liberal enclaves to
make rules for the whole country you
have a whole beautiful gorgeous diverse
incredible country out there these
people aren't interested they're not
they're interested in the way you know
Los Angeles and New York City and
Chicago and you know hate to say it but
even Miami I would say Miami's not
people say oh no Florida's different
Miami
I don't know and I also still think
Florida is going to be closer than
people realize I do I think Florida is
still a really interesting place to vote
we'll see we'll see if I'm wrong if I'm
right but I think when it comes to a
presidential election Florida is going
to be fascinating this next round which
is why I'm really excited to be here for
once I get to vote and maybe the
election doesn't get the results don't
get called within three and a half
seconds after I leave the poll New York
it's like I vote I'm all excited it's
like I'm the Democrat I'm like I'm not
even home yet I'm not even home yet
that's boring so Elena figure out a
different line of work if this is your
perception of what your job should be
that's not what you're there to do and
it's disgraceful that you said it with
no shame she should come out and say oh
my gosh I don't know but no because
media won't hold her accountable for
that nobody will hold her accountable
for that they'll be like they they will
agree oh good we have someone in there
that's easily manipulated by public
opinion amazing that's what we want
forget the law tell what the law that
doesn't matter facts don't matter we
know that
what a bunch of maniacs and it's it's
this ties in a little more to the uh
Erasure of the electoral college but it
the arrogance of people nowadays the
founding fathers were some of the most
educated people of all time they were so
incredibly well read they were so
studied in history they they knew so
much and the arrogance of today that oh
well we live in 2022 so automatically
we're so much smarter than these people
these people knew more than you in the
period 20 stories in the meantime 2022
how much has fallen apart right I mean
they know so much in the meantime
everything's falling apart everywhere
you look I mean it's just Decay rot
breakdown of the family cities Up in
Flames I'll never forget that clip I
forget where it was maybe Charlie would
remember where CNN did a there was a
clip about I don't know if it was some
protest or something and he was like
it's mostly peaceful and it was like
these were on fire a Summer of Love yeah
that's where the mostly peaceful protest
yeah the building was on fire and he's
on live again you know and uh my friend
Jesse Kelly who we're gonna try to get
on here is as well I just had an
exchange with him hopefully he'll come
on he's fantastic and hilarious and
apparently makes the best cheeseburger
ever I need a taste test just gonna say
but he always has this sky as green
Theory where they can convince you of
anything they wanted you to believe the
building's on fire behind you but don't
worry that's not no in the land of make
believe I'm telling you that it's
peaceful so as a result you should
believe that I mean this is this is the
world we're living in if you like the
short clip you can catch another one
here or you can catch the full episode
right here
thank you